Finally!
Alibaba Baby said halleluja, good parker, I wish I knew ya.
I know, I know for sure, that life is beautiful around the world.
I know, I know it's you, you say hello and then I play it over.
Come back baby, cause I'd like to say,
eigentlich müsste ich die Heizung anmachen, weil irgendwie ist es kühl
Problem ist, ich hab die Heizung im Keller ausgeschaltet, ich kann die nicht anmachen
also das Gegenteil davon, das heißt die einzige Möglichkeit die ich jetzt noch habe ist ganz
easy, ich mache einfach Xbox 360, PS4, PS3 und Xbox One an, dann wird es hier auch warm
und ich mache meinen Serverraum auf, da wird es auch warm, big brain, ich bin gleich wieder
da
so, jetzt machen wir noch die Xbox an, wo geht die Xbox, ah jetzt, Xbox angehen, ah jetzt,
perfekt, das ist super effektive Art und Weise zu heizen, ich weiß, wobei ich bin dumm, ich
kann einfach meine Klimaanlage anmachen, die hat doch einen Heizungsmodus, also viel
besser mit vier Konsolen und einem Server zu heizen als mit einer Heizung
gucken, ob der Fabian heute da ist, wir müssen irgendwann noch Geese 4 spielen, wobei es
ja nicht mal Geese 4 aussieht, yes und ich muss noch was aufnehmen heute, ich hab mir
gedacht, ich mach mal ein anderes Video, ich hab mir nämlich noch mal in Ruhe angeguckt,
welche Jugendwörter heute so zur Auswahl stehen, ich dachte mir, ich mach mal ein Video,
wo ich zu den Jugendwörtern reakte, wenn ich wirklich reakte, wenn ich selbst dazu
abgebe, brauch ich irgendwie so ein Titel, so irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, 35-jähriger
Opa Reviewed Jugendwörter oder irgendwie sowas dämliches, da ist schon merkwürdiges
Zeug dabei, was ich ganz komisch finde bei den Jugendwörtern dieses Jahr, ich mein,
die meisten finde ich eigentlich ganz brauchbar, aber was mich wundert ist, da ist total viel
arabisch und türkisch dabei, also gefühlt, gefühlt, so aus dem Kopf jetzt, ich hab jetzt
die Liste nicht, sind 30-40% sind irgendwelche türkischen, arabischen, entweder Redewendungen
oder Wörter, kommt das alles her, reden alle mittlerweile arabisch oder wie, ja Buttergoulang
wurde gelöscht, das hab ich auch gesehen, Buttergoulang wurde gelöscht, warum weiß
ich nicht so genau, das ist ein Begriff, ich mein, es ist nicht so, dass man denen so irgendwie,
Bruder muss los sagen die Leute öfters als Buttergoulang, aber ich mein, warum, war das
Fatshaming oder was, das geht nicht, Fatshaming geht das, wahrscheinlich hat sich irgendjemand
oder irgendeine Gruppe beschwert, dass sie sich geschamed fühlen durch Buttergoulang
und da haben sie, haben die Veranstalter gesagt, ah nee, dann nimm was raus, irgendwie sowas
wahrscheinlich, mittlerweile kannst du ja, mittlerweile bist du ja, kannst dich ja bei
allem darüber aufregen, ich verstehs gar nicht, warum so viel, getriggert ist übrigens auch
dabei als Jugendwort, was ich ganz gut finde, weil mittlerweile ist wirklich jeder über
jeden Scheiß getriggert, ey, wenns danach geht, ja, müsste ich auch täglich bei 50
Sachen getriggert sein, wenn einer was über ein bisschen dickere Leute sagt, instant
triggert, ja, instant, Fatshaming hier, könnte ich mich gleich wieder aufregen, und natürlich
ja auch das alte Klischee, ja, das Hexer nur im Keller sitzt mit Kapuzenpullis auf, ganz
echt, ganz wirklich, wenn du es drauf anlegst, kannst du heute alle 5 Minuten getriggert
sein, was ist das da oben eigentlich für eine komische Leiste, wo kommt die her, warum
ist die Leiste, warum ist auf YouTube die Leiste hier oben so komplett farblich unpassend
zum Rest, das interessiert mich jetzt, ah, das ist die Zeile, die eigentlich News, also
so Benachrichtigungen anzeigen sollt, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass sie anstatt vergessen
haben, die zu verstecken, wenn keine Benachrichtigungen drin ist, das ist ja auch fail, aber die YouTube
Seite wird eh immer grausamer, mittlerweile ist das total wirr, du hast 5-6 verschiedene
Menüs, wo du Sachen einstellst auf YouTube, also du hast das Menü, wo du hochlädst,
es ist ein anderes wie da, wo du deine Videos anguckst, es ist ein anderes wie da, wo du
deine Playlist verwaltest, es ist ein anderes wo du Videos editierst, es ist ein anderes
wie du Cards hinzufügst, es ist ein anderes wo du Endings hinzufügst, es ist mittlerweile
extrem, extrem wirr. Insanely fast mp7 double moab. Moab, und YouTube mein Halo interessiert
mich, wegen dem Adplocker, vielleicht, aber den Adplocker mache ich nicht aus, weil da
gibt es zu viel, latest YouTube Posts, der Bauer hat was gepostet, der Auer. Was ist
das für ein beknacktes Thumbnail, warum soll der komische, was ist das, Spartentyp da irgendwie
mit einer M2, eine SSD, eine SSHD und eine HDD irgendwie anders ausschauen. Das ist
ein total beknacktes Thumbnail. Lul. Omega Lul. Mittlerweile hat es YouTube zumindest
in diesem Browser halbwegs gecheckt, was mich interessiert, die Empfehlungen sind gar nicht
so schlecht. Oh guck mal, da ist sogar ein Video von mir dabei, was ich empfohlen kriege.
Das ist Meta, ich kriege meine eigenen Videos empfohlen. Ja das Ghostreaken Video hat jetzt
nicht so viele interessiert, muss man sagen. Aber da habe ich ehrlich gesagt, als auch
nicht mitgerechnet, dass es genauso viel kriegt, wie irgendwelche CoD Videos oder so, weil
das Game juckt jetzt nicht so viele, im Vergleich zum neuen Modern Warfare oder sowas. Aber
dafür Maximum Sellout. Ich muss euch sagen, ich hätte es auch so in euch gespielt, ich
wusste gar nicht, dass es rauskommt, ich habe es voll verdrängt. Da war da ein Kommentar,
oh das ist richtig, 2019. Riot Shield Nuke. Ok, das müssen wir uns angucken. Das müssen
wir uns angucken, Riot Shield Nuke. Da bin ich mal gespannt, mal gucken, mal gucken ob
das hält, was es verspricht. Riot Shield Nuke. Ups. Warum findet er noch Lobbys? Gibt
es doch eigentlich gar nicht mehr. Echt, gibt es da noch Lobbys? Gibt es da noch Lobbys
oder gibt es da noch Lobbys? Also in Black Ops 1 gibt es kaum noch Lobbys, in CoD 4 gibt
es kaum noch Lobbys. MW2 habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert, da müsste ich erstmal mal eine
DVD wieder finden, weil kaufen will ich es nicht nochmal. Ok, auf gehts. MW2 finden
wir immer noch Hacker Lobbys. Ja, das war ja schon vor 4-5 Jahren so, mittlerweile ist
es immer noch nicht besser. Würde mich zumindest wundern, wenn es besser wäre. Ja, auf dem
PC, auf dem PC, aber das ist ja nicht auf dem PC. Ja, Riot Shield Nuke. Auf die Idee,
das hätte ich ja noch nicht mal probiert früher. Das ist doch übelst frustrierend. Also sowohl
damit zu spielen, als auch dagegen zu spielen. Das Video älter, 3 Monate oder so, ist noch
gar nicht so alt. Vor allem, du siehst ja überhaupt nichts. MKS. Die ganzen Schneiber,
die ganzen 360 Schneiber dudes. Ok, MW2 Nuke konnte übelst easy sein. Konnte. Du musstest
im Prinzip einfach nur bis zum Harrier Kills machen und wenn du Glück hattest, ging's
Harrier Chopper Gunner Nuke. Wenn du Glück hattest, ja. Und die Gegner doof waren. Getreckt.
Nee, der hat auf den Fuß geschossen. Ich fand eigentlich mit einem Schild auf dem Rücken
in Modern Warfare gar nicht so übel, weil das Game war ja so bekannt dafür, dass du
gerne von der Seite oder von hinten erschossen wurdest. Da war so ein Schild auf dem Rücken
gar nicht so schlecht. Dafür war man lahm. Warum change der Kit? Das füllt die Granaten
auf, oder? Wie war das? Ich glaube, das füllt die Granaten und die Secondaries auf, wenn
man Kit wechselt. Der will dann nicht dagegen kämpfen. Das sieht so feil aus mit dem Schild.
Wie sie immer das Schild ins Gesicht gedrückt kriegen. Dann kommt der Hitmarker. Ich finde
das schön an MW2. MW2 war mega frustrierend, weil du durch so viel random Shit gestorben
bist. Das ist mittlerweile auch nicht besser, aber ich finde, MW2 hatte so seinen Höhepunkt
irgendwie. Aber das Coole an MW2 war, dass es so viele abgedrehte Varianten gab und auch
so viele unsinnige Sachen, die trotzdem irgendwie ganz lustig waren. P90 Thermalvisier oder so
ein Bullshit. Das hat eigentlich keiner ernsthaft gespielt. Irgendetwas trotzdem ganz witzig.
Oh, mit Payflow und Harrier. Auf der Map war Harrier und Payflow eh übertrieben geil,
weil die so offen ist. Bei Harrier und Payflow habe ich für Nukes nie gespielt. Ich habe
eigentlich immer nur den Klassiker gespielt. Harrier und dann AC130 oder Chopper Gunner.
Auf Highrise mit Chopper Gunner war halt auch nice. Was macht der da? Man weiß es nicht.
Die Map ist auch nice für Harrier und Payflow. Oh, knapp, knapp. Was? Was ist er denn da?
Was ist er denn jetzt gestorben? Der steht einfach nur da. Hätte ich jetzt eine Facecam,
könnte ich so übelst geile Reaction Videos auf YouTube machen. Die gehen ja eh ab wie
sonst was. Dann würde ich mich jetzt hier hinsetzen und es soll total eskalieren, wenn
ich so ein Video gucke. Über 3 Millionen Views. Easy Money, easy life. Scro, was? Scroozex,
Switch Prime, Dankeschön. Pok. Facecam. Der einzige Grund, oder der hauptsächliche
Grund, warum ich keine Facecam mache ist eigentlich, weil ich nicht will, dass mich Leute morgens
im Zug erkennen. Das führt mir glaube ich voll auf den Sack hin. Wenn ich im Zug morgens
sitze und dann kommt irgendwer, habe ich mich erkannt. Ich will meine Ruhe. Außerdem will
ich in echt nicht mit Leuten interagieren. Menschen in echt gehen mir voll auf den Sack.
Außer der Twitch Chat, der ist okay. I'm like winning this game with a Riot Shield. Harrier,
help me out a little bit, thank you. There goes my Claymore. We're playing on the Afghan
and this Harrier hasn't shot anything. Ah, this sucks. They'd get a pay-blow, call the pay-blow
in. Ja, jetzt ist easy. Einfach in der Ecke sitzen und nichts machen und warten, bis die
Killstreaks gefarmt haben. Oh. Oh my gosh. Das war blöd rauszupen. I should've just crouched
walked right into him. Ja. Instead I tried running right through him. And he shot right through
my shield. E.J., I imagine you could put like a little camo on the shield, that'd be cool.
Come on in, buddy. You're toast. Übrigens, könnt ihr euch noch an Modern Warfare, an
diese Ping-Anzeige erinnern, dass die irgendwie bis 100 oder 150 Millisekunden waren ja noch
in 5 Balken. 5, 1, 2, 3, 4 Balken. Big Muffs. Wie oft wurde Fabian schon im EL angesprochen?
In letzter Zeit ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung. Ist ja nicht mal so präsent. Aber vor ein
paar Jahren, wo ich mal da war, und da war, hat er schon auf YouTube nicht mal allzu viel
gemacht, da war das in der Zeit, wo ich da war und wir irgendwo in diesem, was ist das,
Kaufhaus gewesen sind, war das drei Mal oder so. Das ist schon beim Fabian so. Das ist
dann erst ein paar Leute, die größer sind. Ich mein, so Leute wie, keine Ahnung, Unge
oder Adena oder irgendwie ApoRed oder so, die können gar nicht mehr auf die Straße gehen
ohne, dass Instant irgendwie die Leute am Start sind. Und dann noch schlimmer, überlegt
euch mal, links hier Montana Black kann überhaupt nicht mehr auf die Straße ohne, dass ihn Instant
irgendwie die Gruppe, die Gruppe Schulkinder erkennt. Wusstest du schonmal durch deine
Stimme erkannt? Ja, so ein paar Leute habe ich schon erkannt. Also auf der Gamescom, klar,
auf der Gamescom war es ja auch relativ offensichtlich. Allerdings lustigerweise auch zwei Azubis
zu haben, aber ich habe mein Schild schon nicht verletzt. Hat er gedacht, dass er mich
töten würde? Alles klar, komm schon, ich werde ein Claymore anziehen, gib mir eine Vorwarnung.
Danke, geh rein. Ich werde das hier überheben, nur im Fall, dass ich das Schild von hier her
hinbekommen kann. Das ist sicher ein Schild, der mich hier gesehen hat. Ich bin das hier
runter. Ich meine eigentlich, eigentlich ist es ja nur so zu helfen, eine Riot Shield Nuke,
es ist eigentlich so eine Claymore Riot Shield Nuke. Oh, das wird eng. Ach, der spielt Free
Fall. Das ist eine richtig gute Idee, Free Fall so spielen, weil Team Deathmatch hättest
du viel öfters mal zwei, drei Gegner gegen dich wo du nichts machen kannst. Das ist
Big Brain hier eigentlich, Free Fall zu spielen. Claymores sind in jedem Kott richtig nervig.
Ja, sehr gut, sehr gut. Leute, das hier, ich sage es euch. Ja, Huge Brain. Genau da hätte
ich ihn auch hingesetzt. Ehrlich gesagt hätte ich ihn eigentlich dahin gesetzt. Also der
Pixel sieht deutlich besser aus als da. Ich finde, es ist eigentlich relativ offensichtlich
dass hier der bessere Spot gewesen wäre. Aber hier ist auch okay, hier ist der zweitbeste
Spot. Der hat echt Pech, der ist immer so kurz da vorne nuke bzw. so kurz da vorne
neisse Kills zu kriegen oder wenn er sinnlos gebashed. Das war so, ich hätte wahrscheinlich
schon gleich Rage Quit, den Instant Rage Quit. Ob ihr dazu geflasht wird.
Der will ihn messern oder? Der will ihn messern. Der will ihn messern? Boah, knapp.
Ja, das ist, das ist das Easy Mode Setup. Harrier Chopper Gunner, easy nuke.
Aber der könnte eine Nuke kriegen, ich meine, das sind noch zwei. Alter, das wird mich
so anpissen. Ich hätte Instant Rage Quit, äh, Rage Quit dem Typ irgendwie eine Hate
Voice Message geschickt. Nee, Quatsch hätte ich nicht gemacht. Aber ich hätte Rage Quit
das Game deinstalliert. Point X Fatal. Es gibt ja Leute, die eskalieren ja immer so
richtig, wenn sie irgendwie in Games auf den Sack kriegen. Ich meine, ich sag mal so,
Game Rage Quitten deinstallieren ist das eine, aber du hast ja wirklich welche. Die schicken
dann erstmal eine Hate Message, suchen dich auf Facebook, disliken dich auf Facebook,
flamen dich auf Facebook, flamen alle deine Freunde, deine Eltern, deine Angehörigen
auf Facebook, gehen auf Instagram und posten irgendwie, also es gibt welche, die übertreiben
voll, wenn sie gebashed werden. Und natürlich, ganz wichtig, sie müssen einen schlechten
Rap Disstrack gegen dich aufnehmen. Im Vergleich, falls sich noch irgendjemand an den Hartmann
Disstrack erinnert, gegen die German Taters, im Vergleich zu manchen Hip Hop Geschichten,
die mittlerweile voll angesagt sind, war das sogar irgendwie noch ganz gut. Ich weiß nicht
mehr, was das war, ich hab letztens auf Amazon, auf Amazon kannst du ja so random Zeug hören,
da war irgendeine Hip Hop Playliste, das war irgendeine Deutschrap Geschichte, ich weiß
gar nicht mehr, was das war. Es war nichts, was ich kann, es war dermaßen dämlich, ey.
Ja gut, auf Wasteland Chopper Gunner Beste. Muss ich nur eben verstecken, Chopper Gunner
raus.
Er ist gestorben, oder? Ist er gestorben? Ne, er liegt noch da, er liegt noch da.
Ich glaube, er ist gestorben, man muss jetzt die Nuke im Chopper Gunner kriegen, ne? Jawoll,
ach ne, er lebt noch. Jetzt eigentlich Style Punkt, der hätte jetzt dafür gekriegt, weil
er sich selbst im Chopper Gunner noch gekillt hätte.
Er hätte nicht mehr messern können, das stimmt. Leute, ich hab gerade nicht hingeguckt, hat
er gemessert? Hat er gemessert? Hat er gemessert? Messern? Messern? Nein, nicht, nicht anerkannt,
die Nuke. Die gilt nicht. Leider, leider müssten wir eben die Nuke aberkennen. Leider nicht
gemessert. Ohne Messer nuke nicht valid, ist einfach so. Zu viel, warum Open Worlds nur
noch in Arbeit ausarten? Das ist eigentlich ein Video, vom Titel her, das würde ich mir
angucken. Allerdings, ich kann mir nicht helfen, es gibt ein paar Leute, außer von denen, die
ich offensichtlich nicht gerne gucke, aber es gibt ein paar auf YouTube in Deutschland,
die gucke ich zusätzlich noch nicht gerne und da gehört er dazu. Ich weiß nicht, ich
mag irgendwie die Art und Weise nicht, kann schwer beschreiben, genauso wie ich mir Alexi
Vexi nicht angucken kann. Was? Was? Wish is still a scam. 48$ GTX 1050 Ti und Wish,
ist Wish nicht diese Dropship Plattform? Da wo die ganzen China Dudes ihr Zeug verscherbeln
und dann aus China verschicken und so tun, als kommt sich aus China. Ist das das? Ich
glaube, das ist das.
I recently saw an ad for the e-tailer Wish on YouTube. You know that ad where it's just
a bunch of Millennials massively overreacting to things? Are you like even for real? Are
you seeing this? Are you seeing this? Is it just me or is there like a condescending tone
to that ad? Where it's basically like you can just buy Millennials cheap electronics
off the internet and they're not going to be able to tell that it's s**t.
Es gibt genug Leute, die gut nicht von s**t unterscheiden können. Das hat wahrscheinlich
kaum was mit dem Alter zu tun. Die meisten Leute können gut von s**t nicht unterscheiden.
Wisst ihr was das Schlimmste ist, was die Leute nicht unterscheiden können? Gucken,
dass ich nicht eingeloggt bin. Ah, kann aber. Wisst ihr was das Schlimme ist, was die Leute
nicht unterscheiden können? Die Leute können nicht unterscheiden zwischen sowas hier zum
Beispiel, einem ordentlichen Kopfhörer und einem Creative Fatality-Dings-Headset zwischen
sowas. Und es gibt ernsthaft Leute, die ziehen sich das auf und die ziehen sich das auf und
behaupten sie hören keinen Unterschied. Es ist mir nicht begreiflich, wie das überhaupt
möglich ist da keinen Unterschied zu hören. Das geht eigentlich gar nicht. Das ist sowas
von Pepega. Eigentlich ist es nicht möglich. Ich meine, ohne dass man die schon mal auf
dem Ohr gehabt hat, allein schon, wie das, allein schon, wir nehmen mal einen besseren
Vergleich, wir nehmen acht, weil die sind geschlossen, das passt nicht, die sind glaube
ich halb offen. Das ist besser vom Vergleich her. Also erstens, der Kram kostet einfach
zehnmal mehr. Das allein schon ist jetzt nicht unbedingt, das unbedingt so das Qualitätswerkmal,
aber sag mal so, ein Kopfhörer, der zehnmal mehr kostet, ist zumindest mal ein ganz gutes
Indiz für das, der vielleicht besser ist. Aber allein schon die Polster und die Form,
hier hast du den Kram wenigstens ordentlich auf dem Ohr sitzen, hier hast du den Kram
halb auf dem Ohr draufsitzen. Oh, dass es da wirklich Leute gibt, die unterschiedlich
hören. Ich kann es nicht verstehen. Übrigens, wer einen guten Kopfhörer haben will, der,
ich glaube der da war das, und billig einen ganz guten Kopfhörer, kann sich die Superlux
Dinger angucken. Das ist glaube ich der gleiche China Hersteller, der auch für Sennheiser
oder was, Bio Dynamic, ich weiß nicht mehr, die Kopfhörer teilweise produziert hat, und
der hat jetzt einfach gesagt, ey, scheiß drauf, wir machen jetzt auch Kopfhörer. Und
die sind billig, aber verhältnismäßig gut. Ach stimmt, Beats gibt es ja auch noch. Die
neuen Beats Kopfhörer sollen ganz okay sein, im Vergleich zu den ersten. Ich meine sogar
Cristiano Ronaldo, der Audio Experte, schlechthin hat Beats Kopfhörer auch. Wo kauft der sich
denn jetzt was? GTX 1050 Ti, blablabla, lasst mich raten, am Ende, am Ende ist die Grafikkarte
irgendeine umgelabelte, irgendeine umgelabelte, ähm, drei Generationen alte 7800 GT oder
sowas. 7800 GTX oder irgendwas ganz uraltes, ja. Da ist ein Paket da. Gibt es keinen PP-Gar
mehr? Wie, wir haben keinen PP-Gar? Warum haben wir keinen PP-Gar? Klar müssen wir
einen PP-Gar haben. Haben wir keinen PP-Gar mehr? Warum nicht? Also ich habe ihn nicht
gelöscht. Probiert mal aus, haben wir PP-Gar noch laufen? Ja den können wir auch noch
machen. Wir haben keinen PP-Gar, warum haben wir keinen PP-Gar mehr? Okay, Moment Leute,
ich gucke mal nach. Hatte ich das über FFZ? Stimmt, der wurde entfernt. PP-Gar ist weg.
Ich habe nur noch 24 vor 25 E-Mouts drin. Warum? Hatte ich PP-Gar über FFZ oder über
BetterTwitchTV drin? Da muss ich mal kurz gucken. Wieso geht Lulz rein? Die nur auf
dem Channel, weil die ist halt nur hinzugefügt. Aber ich muss mal kurz in PP-Gar muss wieder
rein. Tatsächlich, die E-Mouts sind weg. Komisch, ganz komisch. Okay, machen wir PP-Gar
wieder hinzu. Add to Channel. Bam. Also BetterTwitchTV, haben wir jetzt wieder PP-Gar drin. Und KekWu
haben wir auch gleich. Das ist der Spanier, der sich kaputt lacht. So, beides drin. Beides
drin. Einfach mal Reload und dann gehts. PP-Gar. Geht nicht, ja dann müsst ihr Reload und vielleicht
dauert es auch ein bisschen bis es drin ist. Ich habe es auf jeden Fall hinzugefügt. KekWu
ist über FFZ und PP-Gar ist über BetterTwitchTV. Hi Max, weißt du ob das Betreiben oder das
Spielen von auf WoW Privatserver erlaubt ist? Denn logisch gesehen würde ich denke ich,
dass das Spieler bezahle und das dann meine Entscheidung aus welchem Server spiele. Jaja,
also spielen darfst du auf jeden Fall auf einem privaten Server. Betreiben darfst du
den privaten Server auch, das ist gar kein Problem. Also keine Rechtsberatung und so,
ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich den irgendwie belegbar voll Ahnung hätte. Aber ich würde
sagen betreiben darfst du den WoW privaten Server auch, es sei denn du benutzt irgendwelchen
irgendwelches Eigentum von Blizzard. Das ist was anderes, wenn du einen WoW Server programmierst
wogegen ein WoW Client connecten kann, du machst das alles selbst und du verwendest
kein Eigentum von Blizzard, dann dürftest du das dürfen. Ich meine im Endeffekt was
brauchst du auf einem Server von WoW was von Blizzard? Ist eigentlich nichts oder? Ich
meine du musst theoretisch die komplette, die komplette, die kompletten Inhalte halt
neu erstellen. Gut wo es Probleme, wo es Probleme geben könnte ist, das Game ist Client-Side,
auf dem Server brauchst du dann nichts. Was brauchst du auf dem Server? Maps sind nicht
auf dem Server, Models sind auch nicht auf dem Server, also das ganze Zeug was Blizzard
Eigentum ist, ist auf dem Client, auf dem Server nicht. Das einzige wo ich mir vorstellen
könnte das es Probleme gibt ist zum Beispiel bei Quest Hexen, die hast du musst du auf
dem Server haben, bei Mobnamen und generell halt bei allem was sich irgendein Typ bei
Blizzard ausgedacht hat. Aber wenn du einfach nur angenommen, du würdest einfach was programmieren
wohingegen sich ein WoW Client connecten kann, dann kann ich mir nicht vorstellen das das
problematisch ist. Ich meine du kannst auch einen Minecraft Server programmieren, du darfst
auch einen Minecraft Server programmieren und wogegen sich ein Minecraft Client connecten
kann, du kannst auch keine Ahnung einen Final Fantasy Server programmieren wohingegen sich
irgendwie Final Fantasy Clients connecten können. Also sogar machbar, ne vom Aufwand her eher
nicht machbar. Ich will nicht wissen wie viel Arbeit in so einem Server drin steckt. Also
ich will nicht wissen wie viel Arbeit in so einem Server drin steckt, also es gab hier
irgendwie Nostalrius und sowas, ich glaube nicht dass die komplett Copyright frei waren.
Was auch ein bisschen problematisch ist, du musst ja den Game Client irgendwie verteilen
und da wird es natürlich schwierig. Du musst ja den Leuten irgendeinen Client zum Download
anbieten wie sie auf deinem Server spielen können. Die meisten Private Servers machen
das so, die lassen dich den offiziellen Client runterladen, kommen vom Hersteller, das ist
ja okay, ist ja in Ordnung und dann bieten sie den Patcher an der quasi die Files ändert
bei dir lokal, dass du bei denen auf dem Custom Server spielen kannst. Das ist würde ich
sagen so eine Grauzone. Aber sag mal sobald du irgendwie Sachen brauchst die sich jemand
bei Blizzard ausgedacht hat oder die irgendjemand bei Blizzard erstellt hat und die kopierst
du einfach, dann ist es natürlich problematisch. Aber solange du den Kram einfach noch nachbaust
ist es okay. Allerdings wirst du mit rein mit nachbauen wahrscheinlich nie einen ansprechenden
WoW Classic Server oder einen WoW FreeShart hinkriegen. Ich habe ja eine Weile hier Dark
gespielt hier auf PlayPhoenix, das ist ein Dark FreeShart und die hatten auch das Problem.
Übrigens die Spielerzahlen sind mittlerweile richtig schlecht geworden. Ja hier so habe
ich aufgehört zu spielen und da spielt jetzt kaum noch einer, am Anfang 4000 Leute, jetzt
1100. Naja zumindest die hatten auch das Problem, dass sie gesagt haben, ja sie wollen ja eigentlich
das Game in ein bisschen älteren Varianten spielbar machen und die haben dann auch Map
Files von alten Gebieten die es nicht mehr gibt ausgeliefert und irgendwann ist dann
der Hersteller gekommen und hat gesagt dürft ihr nicht. Das ist ja was anderes, die haben
ja wirklich Eigentum vom Hersteller verwendet. Hätten die das alles nachgebaut mit eigenen
Maps oder so, dann wäre das wohl wahrscheinlich wieder ok gewesen. Es ist auf jeden Fall nicht
so einfach. Sollte eigentlich nur die Server IP sein, die geändert werden muss im Game.
Es kommt drauf an, was du für einen Stand oder für einen Inhalt anbieten willst. Wenn
du zum Beispiel sagst ich möchte jetzt einen Private Server anbieten für ein Spiel, allerdings
es jetzt nicht mit dem aktuellsten Patch stand, sondern mit keine Ahnung wie das Game vor
drei Jahren gewesen ist, dann musst du vielleicht auch Gebiete ausliefern die es live gar nicht
mehr gibt und dann ist es schon wieder problematisch. Hatten wir das Video mit der GTX nicht schon
mal geschaut? Weiß ich nicht, haben wir das schon mal geschaut? Ich glaube nicht oder?
Moin Max. Serious Max. Das ist ernsthaft. Für mich ist das jetzt immer, seitdem es auf
der Switch rausgekommen ist, ist das für mich immer noch der Switcher. Ich habe mal eine
Idee für einen Stream. Momentan läuft noch eine Reverse Engineering Challenge vom BND.
Diese endet am 15. September. Ab da sollte es kein Problem sein, die Aufgaben öffentlich
zu lösen wäre. Je nachdem, wie schwierig das ist, ist das wahrscheinlich nichts, was
man nebenbei im Stream gestellt ist. Was BND? Reverse Engineering Challenge. Von 2016? Wo?
Hast du mal einen Link? Die Aufgaben findet man momentan nicht mehr auf der Website zum
Video machen sollen, aber Semper Vito hat ein Video zu Level 1 gemacht. Es ist eigentlich
eine gute Idee, manchmal ein Video zu machen, je nachdem, wie schwer das ist. Also ich meine,
unter Reverse Engineering, im Endeffekt, da steckt alles und nichts drinne. Das kann unglaublich
kompliziert und detailreich sein. Bis zu, man hat keine Chance als Normalsterblicher
zu blicken, was abgeht. Bis zu, ich gehe hier in die Details von der Seite und tausche
was aus. Im Prinzip kann da alles drin stecken. Das muss ich mir mal angucken. Wenn du einen
Link hast, können wir uns das mal im Stream anschauen, aber ansonsten muss ich mich erstmal
schlaumen. Die Box ist auf jeden Fall ziemlich klein für eine 1050 GE, oder? Also die da.
Ich finde es schon mal merkwürdig, dass da, da steht nirgendswo NVIDIA drauf, oder?
Da steht nirgendswo NVIDIA drauf. Es ist zwar das NVIDIA Logo manchmal drauf, das NVIDIA
Grün ist drauf. Super Verpackung, gut. Es klebt, jitt.
Haha, der Lüfter, nicht der Lüfter. Ach doch, der Lüfter und der Kühlerblock unten drunter.
Alter, sieht das räudig aus. Guckt euch das mal an. Das sieht aus, wie ein Lüfter aus
einem LG Power Billignetzteil gepaart mit irgendeinem Block Metall drunter. Das sieht richtig
schlecht aus. Die Lüfter sehen außerdem falsch rum aus. Ist wenig drauf, ja. Naja,
wenn das ein Sticker sagt, dann muss das so sein.
VGA? Was zum Teufel ist das? Äh, nein, ja. Ich mein, es sind auch viel zu wenige Anschlüsse.
Ich mein, VGA, HDMI und DVI. Mittlerweile ist es eher so, dass du auf modernen Grafikkarten
hast, keine Ahnung, vier Display-Ports hinten dran oder sowas. Oh, Sub, Michael, 50 Billionen,
genau, Stufe 1, danke. Und wen haben wir dann sonst noch? Creasy08, Twitch Prime und Schniedelwurz,
also quasi Tigerwurz, Twitch Prime. Sehr gut. Ich muss mal gucken, reicht schon für
die ganzen Zaps. Ich muss mal gucken, dass ich nichts übersehen hab. Ne, nichts übersehen.
Zum Glück. Gucken wir mal weiter. Aster0815, zwei Monate, huge, Twitch Prime. Ups, hab
schon ein Fenster verschoben auf der anderen Seite. Woodface. Das ist, im Leben ist das
keine 1050Ti. Im Leben nicht. Wie gesagt, wahrscheinlich ist das irgendwie eine uralt
7900GTX oder 7800GTX, irgendwas so drei, vier, fünf Generationen alt ist oder so. Oder
noch älter. Das erste mit PCI Express. It's not, wer hätte das gedacht. Ich würd mich
gar nicht trauen, das in meinen Rechner zu stecken. Ich hab Angst, dass das Ding irgendwie
im Arsch ist und der PCI Express Steckplatz anfängt zu brennen oder so. Das würd ich
höchstens in irgendeinen Testrechner stöpseln. Oh, habt ihr gesehen, der hat den gleichen
RAM wie ich. Bam, RGB RAM. Beste. Beste RGB RAM. Teuerster sinnloser Blödsinn ever.
RGB RAM. Tut mir auf der Treiber-CD erstmal irgendwie irgendwelche Verschlüsselungstreuer
am Start. Treiber mit Java programmiert, hä?
Okay, wahrscheinlich ist es noch nichtmal. Es ist noch schlimmer als gedacht. Es ist
wahrscheinlich noch nichtmal eine Nvidia-Karte. Es ist wahrscheinlich irgendeine, irgendeine
No Name China-Grafikkarte. Oh, we've got signal. There we go. So it must have been some issue
where it was competing with the APU, but so let's look. Oh, blue screen of death. According
to MSI Afterburner, there's not a graphics card in here. Okay, so let's go to Nvidia.
Nvidia graphics card was not detected in your system. So on this one, it gives the same
warning. According to GeForce Experience, we do actually have a 1050 Ti in here. Yeah,
so I'm gonna install the drivers or update the drivers. This is the second attempt to
install the driver and it actually, the PC blue screened of death while trying to install
the driver. And I don't know if you can tell on camera, but it's actually like flickering.
Like the monitor is like flickering here. So I think what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna take
it out and I'm gonna see what this GPU is, because it's obviously not a 1050 Ti, because
the drivers can't interact with it like it is the graphics card that it says that it
is. So let's... Das ist wahrscheinlich wirklich irgendeine billig China-Grafikkarte. Chen Sen
Extreme Edition. Take off the heatsink and see what GPU we're dealing with. Now I did
see another video where a guy bought, I think it was a GTX 960 off of Wish. And he had
the same thing where like in the software, the graphics card was actually kind of convinced
it was the GTX 960. But when he removed the heatsink, it was a different GPU. I can't
remember what it was. Now mine is also convinced that it's a 1050 Ti, but the graphics card
drivers can't interact with it properly. Kann man den Kram auf Wish eigentlich zurückgeben?
Ich hab da noch nie was bestellt. Ich glaub das ist auch eher so ne Ami-Geschichte. Ich
will da auch gar nix bestellen, weil alle Videos die ich davon sehe sind irgendwelche Scam-Ars-Geschichten.
Gibt es das? Gibt's auf Deutsch? Wish.com. Hab ich mir noch nie angeguckt. Warum scrollt
das? Das verwirrt mich übelst. Ach man muss sich einloggen, dass man was kaufen kann mit
Facebook. Wird ja immer schlimmer. Also ich krieg ja schon Motionsignis allein schon wenn
ich die Seite öffne. Näh. Warum haben wir eigentlich 290 Zuschauer? Das ist ja huge
Pock. Was ist mit der Wärmeleitpaste los? Sieht aus wie Zahnpasta.
Was? Ne GTS 450? Was ist denn bitte schon ne GTS 450?
Von wann ist die vorab? Von wann ist das Ding? Date. Steht da irgendwo was? X12, okay die
kann doch nicht so alt sein. Von wann ist denn das? GTS 450 hab ich nie gehört. Ohne
30 Euro Grafikkarte ist das. Aha, nice. Einfach mal ne 30 Euro Grafikkarte umlabeln. Auf
4050 Ti, lustig. Naisu. Ja, die kostet neun 30 Euro.
Boah, das ist schlecht.
Das ist richtig schlecht. Haben die das irgendwie drauf geklebt auf das Board?
Na gut, das müssen wir vom Bücher angucken, wie das Mios flasht oder so, weil ich mal
ganz ehrlich, die Karte selbst wenn die funktioniert, die ist so alt, damit kann eh kein Mensch
was anfangen. Also das ist richtig fail. Das ist richtig fail. Okay, was haben wir als
nächstes? Installing MS-DOS on a new gaming PC. Oh ja, nice. Der Typ macht eh gute Videos,
die guck ich gern, das ist bestimmt gut. Ist das mein Gehäuse? Das ist das mein Gehäuse?
Das ist, oder? Ja, das ist ein Fractal Design R4. Huge case. Ja, da ist es. Beste. Beste
Case. Wobei, also ich hab zwei Rechner hier stehen, die sehen fast exakt identisch aus.
Einer ist ein R5 und das andere ist ein R4. Gibt's eigentlich mittlerweile ein R6? Oh,
gibt's ein R6? Moment, hab ich vielleicht schon ein R6? Ich glaub, ich hab schon ein
R6, oder? Wann hab ich ihn in mein Rechner gekauft? 21. Oktober 2017. Ah, nee, ich hab
noch ein R5, ich hab noch kein R6. Schon ein R7? Nee. Aber ist eh kein großer Unterschied,
ne? Sieht immer noch genauso aus. Haben wir mal das Gehäuse von außen? Es sieht immer
noch genauso aus, wie... Wisst ihr, was mich voll verwirrt, wenn man da hinklickt, dass
es dann so komisch scrollt, oder? Das sieht original aus. Also das sieht fast genauso...
Alter, was ist das für ne Seite? Fuck. Die Seite ist kaputt. Jupp. Ich schaff's immer
an, irgendwelche Webseiten kaputt zu machen. Das sieht fast noch genauso aus, wie das R4,
oder? Ja. Schwarzer Kasten eben. Ah, aber ziemlich nicer, Schwarzer Kasten, weil vor allem mit
Staubfiltern und sowas. Ja, stimmt, hat das USB-C, müssen wir mal gucken. Sieht nicht
so aus, ne? Sogar das R6 hat noch die alten. Das sieht ohne Scheiß, Leute, das sieht original
aus, wie mein R5. Ich seh da überhaupt keinen Unterschied. Außer, dass bei meinem R5 die
USB-3-Anschlüsse blau sind, so wie das eigentlich sein müsste. Naja, wurscht. Schau ganz an,
wie Redos installiert. Das gibt's auch mit USB-C, okay. So schlimm sind es mittlerweile
bei USB schon, ne? Dass du mittlerweile drei verschiedene Gehäusesorten brauchst für
den Unterschied zwischen USB-Stecker. Vielleicht ist das von Wish, genau. Aber die Fractal Design
ist die Magische. Das ist die Gehäuse, das ist die Magische, das ist die Gehäuse, die
Magische. Das funktioniert doch im Leben nicht. Na wobei, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, ich
glaub, ich glaub, das funktioniert. Du wirst da nichts damit benutzen können, richtig, aber
installieren wirst du es wahrscheinlich können. Wahrscheinlich kannst du DOS einfacher installieren
auf dem aktuellen PC als Windows 95. Moment, hat er überhaupt ein Floppy-Laufwerk?
Hast du das noch nie mit einem neuen Computer gemacht?
Also was wir hier nutzen werden, um all das zu erreichen, ist eine externe USB 3,5 Inch Floppy
Disk Drive mit einem MS-DOS Boot Disk. Und du weißt, ich hab' das eigentlich nie auf einer
modernen Maschine ausprobiert, nur mit einem USB-Floppy, aber wir werden sehen, ob es funktioniert.
Ich geh' einfach in die Bios hier rein und schaue die Boot-Settings, um zu sehen, ob sie es
als Boot-Device sieht. Und ja, es ist ein USB-Floppy-Drive, das da oben aufsteht. Also,
ich glaube, DOS installieren dürfte wirklich kein großer Akt sein. Ich mein, du kannst
da wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich das Zeug deine Hardware ordentlich verwenden danach, aber
installieren wird wahrscheinlich gehen.
So, ich werde sehen, wie F-Disk diese 500GB M.2 SSD handelt. Das fragt, ob ich Large-Disk-Support
anbieten will, denn diese Version des Programms, die ich eigentlich benutze, ist von Windows 98.
Und es erkennt es als eine feste Disk-Drive, also werde ich ihr sagen, dass ich die maximale
disponible Größe für den primary-DOS-Partition benutze.
Also, alles klar, jetzt versuchen wir, das C-Drive zu formatieren. Und, naja, es sagt, dass es
18,18.5 MB ist. Ich glaube, das sind 18 GB und 180 MB oder so. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Es könnte eigentlich die ganze 512 GB sehen, und es ist einfach nicht richtig zu zeigen.
Einerseits wird das viel zu lange dauern, um das zu machen.
Ich glaube, F-Disk kriegt es einfach nicht richtig angezeigt, ja?
Das wird lange dauern. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das machen will. Ich will das nicht machen.
Also, ich gehe zurück und werde es nicht mit dem C-Drive machen.
Ich werde es nur mit den zwei GB limitieren, die ich weiß, dass MS-DOS mitarbeiten wird.
Und in dieser Zeit ist es ganz gut und formatiert sehr, sehr schnell.
Wir geben es hier einen Volumen-Label, der für diese Situation geeignet ist.
Und da haben wir einen formatierten C-Drive, der bereit ist, MS-DOS zu installieren.
Die Frage ist nur, wieso. Das ist ganz einfach zu beantworten, weil er wissen will, ob es geht.
Das ist eine Sache, die kann ich nachvollziehen.
Ich bin geneigt dazu, das selbst mal auszuprobieren.
Weil ich habe hier hinten noch genug olle PC-Krampel rumfliegen, ne?
Bei der Gelegenheit müsste ich wirklich mal ausprobieren, ob man da nicht Windows 95 drauf installieren kann.
Das ist MS-DOS 6.22, so ist es ziemlich normal. Es sieht es einfach wie jeder andere PC, den es als DOS sehen würde, denn DOS ist es nicht.
All das, was es weiß, ist, dass es einen A-Drive, einen C-Drive und einen PC gibt, den es installieren kann.
Das ist das, was es tun wird, wenn diese drei floppen, MS-DOS komplett installiert wird.
Wir starten den Computer an und, naja, es sieht nicht aus.
Ich habe den Disk-Drive komplett ausgedrückt, ging in den BIOS und habe sichergestellt, dass es nur von dem einen internen Drive geht und es einfach nicht funktioniert.
Also, was das System sucht, ist es einfach nicht zu finden mit MS-DOS 6.22.
Jedoch, wenn ich mit einem floppigen Disk starte und dann auf den C-Drive gehe, kann man sehen, dass alles da ist und MS-DOS jetzt funktioniert.
Nur für die Hölle davon. Lass uns den Disk starten und sehen, wie das funktioniert. Wow, das war instantaneous. Ich meine, ich hätte nichts weniger erwartet, aber ich dachte, das war ein bisschen amüsant.
Alles klar, es ist Zeit, ein paar Spiele zu probieren und ich habe Commander Keen Episodes 1 und 4 auf einem floppigen Disk hier.
Wir werden sie einfach über den C-Drive kopieren und dann probieren wir Commander Keen 1.
This is a 16-color EGA game and it's booting up just fine. However, it's kind of hard to see in this, because my camera was correcting for it a little bit, but the colors are wrong.
They're not nearly as vivid as they should be. The white is tinted a little bit green.
Ja, mit einem Gaming-PC aus 2019 sehen halt einfach 20 Jahre alte Games schlechter aus als vor 20 Jahren, ne?
...Speakers here and nope, still no sound whatsoever. So apparently you just have to find a PC-Speaker and install it in this computer. There is a motherboard header that you can plug it into.
Also ernsthaft mal Leute, PC-Speaker, ich glaube das erste, was ich immer abziehe, wenn es abzuziehen geht, ist der PC-Speaker.
Aber meistens ist es halt drauf, kannst du eh nix machen.
Ja, das sieht auf jeden Fall nicht original aus.
Da zeigt er noch ein bisschen was von DOS.
Ja, das Video ist doch nicht so interessant, wie ich mir das gedacht habe.
Was ich irgendwie dachte, da kommt noch ein bisschen mehr. Aber es hat sich einfach installieren lassen, ne? Es ist ja im Prinzip easy.
Also ich bin echt geneigt, das selbst mal auszuprobieren, ne? Ich hab hier hinten nochmal meinen vorletzten Rechner stehen.
Das ist ne, was ist denn das? Warte mal, stimmt. Der da ist das.
Ja, von 2013. Da steht hier noch, boop, ausrangiert, aber steht halt in der Ecke rum. Da ist drinne ne 500G SSD, HD 7079 und nen Vierkern Xeon.
Da bin ich echt geneigt mal auszuprobieren, ob ich auf dem Ding nicht Windows 95 installieren kann.
Pananyan schreibt, ich wusste gar nicht, dass Spiele für MS-DOS so gut ausgesehen haben. Ernst gemeint. Ja gut, die meisten DOS-Spiele, das waren halt Pixel-Grafik-Games. Pixel-Grafik-Games haben halt den riesen Vorteil, ich finde das sieht man auch an den Super Nintendo-Spielen, dass das gut altert.
Pixel-Grafik altert gut. Die ersten 3D-Grafiken sehen halt aus heutigen Gesichtspunkten scheiße aus. Ich finde so die allerersten, so die richtig basic 3D-Sachen, so wie Mario 64 und so, ich finde die kann man sich heute immer noch halbwegs angucken, einfach weil es vieles schlicht und ergreifend nicht gab, was schlecht aussehen kann.
Aber guckt euch mal Half-Life 1 oder sowas an, das sieht aus heutigen Maßstäben einfach reudig schlecht aus.
Da ist bei Pixel-Grafik kaum Improvements bis heute. Ja, Pixel-Grafik, wenn du von handgemalten Pixel-Grafiken sprichst, ist halt die Frage, was willst du improven bei handgemalten Pixel-Grafiken? Du kannst halt die Auflösung höher machen.
Also das probiere ich glaube ich mal aus. Da mache ich ein Video zu Windows 95 installieren auf einem alten PC. Lulwe, Wub-Lul, das waren wir. So, was haben wir denn als nächstes Video zu bieten?
Ah, den heben wir uns auf, den gucken wir uns auch noch an. Intel Marketing ist zurück, also sprich, damit ist ja wahrscheinlich wieder gemeint, dass Intel irgendeinen Marketing-Fail getrieben hat, weil Intel hat ja eigentlich gar keine Marketing-Abteilung.
Das sehen wir mal als nächstes. This is the most underused gun in Modern Warfare 2. Das hat wirklich kein Mensch gespielt. Mein neuer Rechner, was ist drin? Nee, das können wir zu machen.
Wollen wir noch ein MP2-Video gucken? Ansonsten gucken wir uns Mario Kart Rainbow Road an. Moment, was zum Teufel ist das? 40.000 RPM Lego Motor.
Was geht mit dem ab? Lul.
MonkaS Smoke, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Okay, die Idee muss erst mal kommen.
Was ein Schwachsinn, warum?
Oh, jetzt ist die Stange durchgebrochen, hä?
Was ist das für ein Bullshit?
Oh, MonkaS Smoke.
Leute, wisst ihr was? Ganz ernsthaft, so Zeug fehlt auf YouTube Deutschland. YouTube Deutschland ist einfach der Sack schlechthin.
Es ist nicht so, dass international es nicht den gleichen Bullshit gebe, wie in Deutschland, bloß dass es international noch ordentliche Sachen gibt.
Man kann sich jetzt rüber schreiben, ob das ordentlich ist, aber sowas fehlt auf YouTube Deutschland. Einfach mal ein sinnloses Video, wo einer seinen Lego Motor smoket.
Das müssen wir uns auch irgendwann nochmal angucken, weil das ist ein echt guter Vortrag, aber das machen wir nicht heute, weil eine Stunde und sonst was ist zu hardcore.
YouTube Deutschland gleich ungereagiert auf Tanzverbot, ja so ungefähr. Oder wir spielen, seit wann, jetzt ernsthaft Leute, seit wann ist Glücksspiel eigentlich wieder angesagt?
Es ist auf Twitch und auf, ich meine damit jetzt nicht irgendwie Poker oder Lootboxen öffnen, sondern so richtig klassisches Automaten, Slot Machine, Singsburgs Glücksspiel.
Seit wann ist das dann wieder angesagt? Ja, seit Monta es macht, aber Monta macht das wahrscheinlich auch nur, weil es angesagt ist, oder?
Der ist da wahrscheinlich einfach nur aufgesprungen, weil ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass er morgens aufgestanden ist und ich gedacht habe, ey Leute, lass mal ein bisschen Automat on Stream spielen.
Seit wann, seit wann ist Glücksspiel so in der klassischen Form eigentlich wieder angesagt?
Doch, genau so, okay. Aber warum guckt man das? Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, was einem das gibt. Also ich hab das ja letztens auf Twitter auch schon gefragt, da haben mir Leute erklärt, das gibt so, es gibt wohl so Hobbypsychologen am Start auf Twitter.
Es gibt wohl so, wenn du selbst darauf stehst und nicht spielen willst und nicht spielen kannst, dass du quasi jemand anderes beim Spielen zuguckst, weil das irgendwie für so Leute dann so Ersatzspielen ist, weiß nicht wie man das genau nennt.
Aber ich verstehe null, was einem das gibt. Trockenspielen sozusagen, ja. Also auf Deutsch haben Monta und Knossi das losgegeben. Ja, Knossi habe ich mir auch letztens angeguckt, das habe ich keine zwei Minuten ausgehalten.
Oh Mann, jetzt nicht das Falsche hier. Oh, ich raste aus. Nur dann habe ich mir gedacht, Alter, warum guckt man sich das an? Ich verstehe es nicht, ich verstehe es echt nicht.
Ich verstehe, also ich sag gar nicht, dass die Leute, die das machen, dass das irgendwie, dass das von denen ihrer Seite jetzt irgendwie super, irgendwie Leute beschissen oder so ist es ja eigentlich gar nicht. Man kann sich ja selbst überlegen, aber ich verstehe nicht, warum man das guckt. Das releuchtet mir nicht ein.
Ja, das ist nicht so, wie ich sage, hey, ich verstehe nicht, warum man Deutschrap hört. Ich finde es übelst bescheuert zum größten Teil, aber ich kann das irgendwie noch nachvollziehen. Ich kann nachvollziehen, dass es Leute gibt, denen das gefallen und die hören halt auch eben die Musik, die ihnen gefällt.
Okay, aber was, was gibt es einem, irgendwelche Spielvideos zu gucken? Das verstehe ich nicht. Das leuchtet mir echt nicht ein. Und sowas gibt es international in der Art und Weise nicht.
Also ich weiß nicht, es ist ganz merkwürdig YouTube Deutschland.
Dazu wird dann noch Reacted, der Reacted auf Reaction macht. Also so Reaction Inception gibt es international auch nicht, in der Art und Weise. Was du international hast, sind Leute, die quasi auf irgendwas reacten und das so ein bisschen auseinandernehmen. Gibt es in Deutschland auch ein paar Channels?
Letztens habt ihr das mitgekriegt, es gab irgendeinen, ich hab ganz vergessen, ich hab vergessen, wie der heißt, irgendein asiatischer Channel oder zumindest ein Asiater als Channel Betreiber, ich glaube Koreaner.
Der hat irgendwie einen Spendenaufruf gemacht, dass man für seinen Vater, für die bessere Behandlung oder so, der ist wohl irgendwie krank, für seinen Vater, dass man irgendwie spenden soll. Und die Leute haben dann irgendwie 100.000 Dollar gespendet.
Dann hat er quasi irgendwie zwei oder drei Tage, nachdem er quasi 100.000 Euro Spenden bekommen hat, ein Video hochgeladen, mein neues Haus, das krasse Luxusleben in meinem neuen Haus, so nach dem Motto.
Und da waren die Leute halt irgendwie ein bisschen empört drüber, dass er in dem einen Video sagt, hier spenden für meinen Vater und spenden, dass wir das alles bezahlen können und so und danach sein krasses Lifestyle-Haus zeigt.
Das ist schon ziemlich dumm, ja. The Korean Savage, genau der war das hier, der stimmt.
Ja, genau, genau, genau. Mal gucken, ob das Haus-Video am Start ist. Ja. New-House-Tour. Setup-Tour.
My god, guys, we are at... Ha, comments disabled, lul. Comments disabled. Likes, dislikes disabled. Warum nur? Warum nur? Hm, woran könnte das denn liegen?
Naja. Und was ist das Call of Duty-Videos?
Wobei mittlerweile, ganz ehrlich, Call of Duty-Videos, toll, sollen die Leute ruhig weiter Call of Duty-Videos machen, weil man hat es in Deutschland gesehen, die nächste Evolutionsstufe nach Call of Duty-Videos sind RL-Prank-Videos.
Viele deutsche Channels, die mit Call of Duty-Videos angefangen haben, sind jetzt zu Prank-Videos, zu Lifestyle-Videos, zu Deutschrap, zu Deutschrappern geworden.
Dann sollen die Leute lieber bei Call of Duty-Videos bleiben. Das ist doch das kleinere Übel.
Wir haben schon genug. Ich möchte gerne Deutsch-Prank-Rapper in Deutschland, in YouTube-Deutschland.
Der hat irgendwie ein Video gemacht, wo er halt um Spenden, Spenden aufgerufen hat für seinen Vater. Und ein paar Tage später hat er halt sein krasses Lifestyle-Video hochgeladen.
Unabhängig davon, ich kann mir da jetzt keinen Urteil drüber erlauben, ich kenne, ich gucke ihn nicht, ich habe das zum ersten Mal von ihm gehört, wie die Situation wirklich ist, kann ich überhaupt nichts zu sagen.
Aber, eine Sache muss man echt mal sagen, das Timing ist wirklich saumäßig dämlich.
Das Timing ist wirklich unglaublich bescheuert, ein Video zu machen, ich brauche Spenden und drei Tage später mein neues Haus mit krassen Lifestyle.
Das Timing ist einfach richtig dumm. Ja, also das ist wirklich total hängen geblieben.
So, wir gucken jetzt, wir gucken jetzt ein MW2-Video. Genau, erstmal Fortnite-Gameplay, da gibt es wenigstens ordentliche Views.
Aber was gucken wir jetzt an? LR86, ne L86 LSW mit Heartbeat-Sensor.
Wo geht's los? Ich glaube, mit der Waffe habe ich in MW2 insgesamt keine Ahnung, 20 Kills gemacht oder so, wollte ich nie spielen.
10% off at checkout and let's get right into the video.
Genau, hier. Ich glaube, das ist das Video. Oder ist es das Video?
Sein Vater ist zumindest krank und er hat um Spenden für seinen Vater gebeten.
Und dann hat er halt quasi, nachdem die Spendenkampagne auf GoFoundMe abgeschlossen war, hat er quasi den Video hochgeladen,
so nach dem Motto guckt euch mein krasses neues Haus mit dem krassen Gaming-Lifestyle an.
Das Timing war halt unglaublich bescheuert.
Naja, also richtig, das Timing ist wirklich dämlich.
Alright, so first off, the only reason I got a Heartbeat-Sensor on, because I didn't know it had one for this gun.
Heartbeat-Sensor? Ob null?
Did he copy my class, bro? He's gonna have no fun using this thing. Alright, let me go get this kid under here.
Heartbeat-Sensor helps out.
Ist was? Gab es eigentlich in MW2 was, wo man sowas wie Ghost, Cold-Blooded war das, oder?
Cold-Blooded. Da war man auch nicht auf dem Heartbeat-Sensor drauf.
So much recoil, bro.
Alright, I'm putting a Claymore here. This guy's really taking my class, there's no way he's gonna have any fun with it.
This thing does melt, though. I gotta call these in real quick. Squirrelim's getting a little bit close.
While I'm making the comeback, I forgot I had to make the comeback.
The thing has pretty good damage, but the recoil is just so awfully absurd.
I got a chopper gunner, dude, no way. This is my first game on right now.
And I'm probably not gonna just use Heartbeat-Sensor, I wanna use a bunch of different attachments, too, so.
I wanna use Red Dot, I wanna use Holographic, probably Grip.
Alright, you know what, do I just call this in down here?
Yolo, 11-0, this guy's a 16-9-9.
I'm probably gonna take off Chopper Gunner, by the way.
Chopper oder AC-130 auf Terminal war ja richtig huge.
I think that Prednis will hit me and I almost die.
You're dead.
Oh, Leute, wisst ihr was wir uns danach noch angucken müssen? So old-school-mäßig.
War das nicht Solution mit der Penta Nuke?
Triple Nuke?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es gar nicht, wer war das denn jetzt mit der Penta Nuke?
Dann hat er, dann hat er, Danny hat da noch, äh, CoD-Videos gemacht.
Egal, jetzt gucken wir aber erstmal in hier.
Rambo-Penta-Nuke-Fake.
Alter, was ist da in der Luft?
Alter, was ist da in der Luft gerade los?
Die ganze Map besteht aus Killstreaks.
Er muss messern, messern.
Ah, keine korrekte Nuke hat nicht gemessert.
Ach nee, kann er gar nicht liken.
Bin ich eingeloggt?
All die werden übrigens weggesprayt, oder er weggesprayt.
Das ist ein beknackter Name, habt ihr das gesehen?
Oh mein, die hat das Gesicht genubetubt.
Die Beleuchtung war da wirklich so komisch in dem Raum.
Oh, wär das nice, wenn ich noch mit dem Xbox-Controller umgehen könnte.
Na gut, ich hab ja meinen Tastaturadapter.
Die Hacks sind real.
Sind das neu?
Ja, die sind relativ neu.
Also anscheinend gibt es immer noch Lobbys.
Ich müsste das mal ausprobieren.
Wie gesagt, Black Ops 1 ist tot, was Games angeht.
Und Code 4 ist auch tot.
Ich müsste mal wieder MW2 ausprobieren.
Weggesprayt.
Was? Der war raus.
Das ist unfair, der hat geleckt.
Ich glaube, ich installiere nachher mal MW2.
Muss ich mal eine DVD suchen.
Muss mir doch...
Xbox Gold.
Ja, übrigens Leute, wollen wir das weiter gucken.
Es lohnt sich gerade, Xbox Gold zu holen, bzw. den Ultimate Pass.
Weil da kriegt ihr das neue Gears of War für 1 Euro.
Also der Ultimate Pass kostet gerade für einen Monat nur 1 Euro.
Und da ist das neue Gears of War drinne.
Also das lohnt sich tatsächlich gerade mal, einen Monat lang Xbox Ultimate zu holen.
2 Monate 2 Euro, aber danach regulär.
Also am besten einfach abschließend direkt kündigen, dass man es gar nicht vergessen kann.
Der geht schon gut ab, der Typ, der ist echt gut.
Alter, wie sie reinrennen.
In MW2 ist so viel Unlicht drumherum explodiert und passiert, das war echt nicht normal.
Erstmal weg, Auto Shotgun.
Oh, ich dachte er ist in die Clammer gerannt.
Da siehst du immer wenn du gegen halbwegs kompetente Gegner spielst, die machen deinen Harrier direkt weg.
Hast du noch Kontakt zum Friseur, ja klar.
Wir haben vor 2 Tagen zusammen gestreamt.
Aufgekackt.
Die Map, das ist eine meiner wenigsten gemachten Maps in MW2.
Weiß nicht wie es euch da geht, aber die Railtratten fand ich von Anfang an.
Kacke.
Alter, was geht mit dem Typ ab, die sind alle übelst am rumpen.
Das macht übelst Damage.
Aber in MW2 hat alles Damage gemacht.
Am besten in MW2 war der russische Announcer, wenn AC130 am Start ist.
Kennt ihr den noch?
Das ist aber MW3.
Den da meine ich, den Typ.
Das war der beste.
Tango Sucker.
Tango Hatter, genau.
Tango Hatter.
Ja das war klar, also wenn der von hinten weg klatscht.
Der hatte noch ein schlechteres Controller-Aim, der Gegner.
Steckt.
Noch mehr steckt.
Hyper steckt.
Jetzt gleich, Pavlo raus.
Da steckt dich Alpha, einfach nichts machen, du brauchst ja nur 8 Kills.
Ich finde auf der Map hat man übelst schlechte Gegner gesehen.
Wie oft ist das passiert, wie oft ist euch das passiert?
Du hast ein Killstreak gekriegt, der nächste Gegner den du gesehen hast, BAM hat dich gekillt.
Aber besser so rum als andersrum.
Messer, Messer, Messer, Messer.
Schon wieder keine Legend.
Der hat es wirklich verdient, dass die Leute gucken, der spielt gut und die Videos sind unterhaltsam.
Guck mal, der macht nur Oldschool-Cod-Videos.
Die Leute gucken es, das finde ich sehr nice.
Pogas, das ist so alt, wahrscheinlich will er das Video selbst gar nicht mehr wissen, dass es existiert.
Ach, er hat gar nicht erzählt dabei, einfach nur Sound.
Das ist die Musik von Charlie, Charlie Petro, wo alle damals die Musik genommen haben.
Charlie Paradelrigo, irgendwie so, das haben damals alle genommen die Musik.
Intro, ok Intro please.
Stimmt, ja.
Wie ist der Cod denn?
Das ist aber übelst nice, die Musik hier dabei.
Hat er sich eigentlich bei dir gemeldet wegen dem Video, ja, wir nehmen was zusammen auch demnächst.
Vor allem, man beachte mal die Huge-Quality, die man damals hochgeladen hatte mit 720p.
Alter, die Musik war so nice.
Da werden sie weggesprayt.
Stimmt, das waren nur HD-PVR-Aufnahmen, wie genau.
Ich war damals der Einzige mit einer ordentlichen Black-Magic-Karte gefühlt.
Alle hatten einen komischen Analog HD-PVR.
Der PS3 hat es ja auch nicht erlaubt, eine HDMI aufzunehmen.
Erstmal Mutant Crosscut.
Will der nicht oben rein schießen jetzt mal?
Ah ne, dreifach.
Alter, die werden gebashed.
Ach, das ist ja die Triple Nuke, das ist wieder so ein Gameplay, wo ich mich frage, warum liefen die Gegner nicht?
Die wollen gebashed werden.
Die finden es geil gebashed zu werden, es gibt ja so Leute.
Der Typ.
Weißt du, damals haben die Leute sowas hochgeladen, heute laden die Leute hoch, wie sie Automat spielen.
Also jetzt nicht Solution, aber was auf YouTube-Deutschland teilweise unterwegs ist.
Das war nicht so ordentlicher Content insofern, dass er nicht spielen können musste.
Und jetzt gibt es keine Musik mehr.
Ist das das Game of Thrones Team?
Gab es das damals überhaupt schon?
Das war die erste Staffel, oder?
Das müsste mit die erste Staffel gewesen sein, oder?
Ne, noch ein bisschen älter, die erste Staffel war glaube ich noch ein bisschen länger her.
Damals habe ich auch noch gekoppt bis Staffel 3, danach wurde es mir zu dumm.
Das war damals noch nicht wirklich so Mainstream-mäßig.
Jetzt erst so ab Staffel 3, 4 dann. Staffel 1, 2 über Slow Budget.
Ah, Game of Thrones ist schon so alt. Gute Nacht Staffel!
Muss mindestens 8 Jahre alt sein.
Jetzt nochmal AC130 in your face.
Das hat nicht getroffen, das erste. Warum nicht?
Das hat ja Sandy Ravage immer drin.
Danach müssen wir uns noch die Sandy Ravage Montage angucken.
So, 2 Nukes hat er jetzt schon, ne?
Habt ihr es gerade gehört? Taktischer Sprengkopf bereit zum Start.
Damals haben die Leute noch die Games auf Deutsch gespielt.
Oh, knapp. Die Gegner sind schon hardcore dumm.
Er hat aber schon übelst gekämpft. Was willst du denn machen?
Was willst du denn machen? Hier fliegt alles um die Ohren rum.
Außerdem ist das nicht Campen im eigentlichen Sinne.
Campen im eigentlichen Sinne machen ja nur Nukes, die sonst nichts geschissen kriegen.
Das ist einfach nur taktisch gespielt an der Stelle, wo man taktisch spielen muss.
Genau PS3 Gameplays zählen nicht. Xbox Gameplays beste.
Die sind voll in die Granate reingespornet.
Jetzt schreckt.
Wo ist die 3. Nuke oder hat er die schon am Start?
Ja, alle schon am Start, oder? Zwar ist das die 3. Nuke.
PS3 waren mehr Nukes. Na klar, weil du auf der PS3 für Online-Spiel nichts bezahlen musstest.
Und dann hat sich Sony gedacht, bei der PS4, das kann ja nicht sein.
Man muss da was bezahlen.
Ich meine, das sind schon übelste Kacknust. Aber die werden so krass gebashed, ey.
Vor allem die Video-Quali, du kannst ja alles in Pixel zählen gerade.
Messer, Messer, 360, ja, 360 gilt auch. Die ist legit die Nuke.
Und hier 360. Fuck.
Und jetzt nochmal The Legend himself.
Genau, das hier. Das ist eines der besten Montages ever.
Vor allem die Video-Quali, guckt euch das mal an. Das sieht aus wie, das kann mein Klo besser aufnehmen.
Wir haben in der Kamera abgefilmt, sieht besser aus.
Ich will nicht wissen, ob ich diese Montage geguckt habe damals.
Ich weiß nicht, 50 Mal oder so.
Ich meine, das Editing war für die damalige Zeit absolut next-gen.
Kennst du Asiali 80? Klar. Da ist die Moab.
Stimmt, damals haben die ja noch mit der Kamera vom Bildschirm abgenommen.
Aber Alberto hat damals noch mit der Kamera das Zeug vom Bildschirm aufgenommen.
Das Editing war für die Zeit wirklich seinerzeit voraus.
Ich meine, heute locken sie damit kein Hintergrund mehr vor.
Einfach ein bisschen Sprache, Farbfilter, Overlay, Text.
Aber für die Damalige war es echt nice.
Und es ist im Prinzip immer noch.
Das sieht fast aus wie mit dem USB Scrapper aufgenommen.
Der CS konnte es auch besser editieren, weil CS damals auch schon Replay-Modus hatte.
MB2 nicht.
Ah, jetzt hat er geschwitzt, als er gestorben ist, hat er Krallate.
Alter Face, was ist das für eine Quali?
Die beste Mounted von früher fand ich immer noch die Optik Predator.
Ich glaube, ich kann mich noch dunkel dran erinnern, oder?
Das war hier die Quad 4 Remake-Rap.
Spaß, du warst.
Das fand ich eigentlich das Cool an MB2.
Du konntest mit fast allen Ubils trauen, allerdings wurdest du auch auf so viele Bullshit-Wege gekillt.
Dazu gibt es nur zu sagen.
I Reaped war auch immer geil. War das nicht der Typ, wo alle gedacht haben, es ist ein Mädel und war es dann gar nicht?
Da war doch irgendwas.
Ich kann mich da noch so dunkel dran erinnern.
Das ist doch das, wo sie alle vermutet haben, das war irgendein Mädel und dann kam dann irgendwie raus und es war es nicht.
Das war die Zeit, wo ich die Leute dafür noch interessiert habe.
Und ich meine, man muss mal realistisch sein.
Ich weiß nicht, was in den Leuten damals vorgegangen ist, wer ernsthaft glauben konnte, dass es 2008 oder 2011 allen Ernstes Mädels gegeben haben könnte, die MB2 360 Quickscope Montages gemacht haben.
Allein schon das anzunehmen ist total beknackt. Natürlich musste das ein Typ sein.
Salena, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Oh, ich habe noch einen Sub vergessen.
Gull Lager, Dankeschön, Twitch Prime, den haben wir noch. Erik ist stolz, alles klar, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, nice.
Auch Dankeschön, nice. Ich habe mich voll übersehen bei dem ganzen Video.
Cute Chat, wo ist der Cute Chat heute?
Cute Chat, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
So eine nice Montage.
Ja, das war doch nice.
Und jetzt müssen wir es noch angucken. Rambo, wie hat man den geschrieben? Rambo Penta Duke Fake. Gibt es das Video überhaupt noch?
Servus Leute, Rambo. Servus Leute, da ist er.
Das Urteil, stimmt. Das Urteil hat er immer hochgeladen. Damals hat es die Leute noch voll interessiert.
Wo ist die Penta Duke? Gibt es nicht mehr, die ist gelöscht, kann das sein? Ist die Penta Duke weg?
Ja, gibt es nicht mehr. Das war doch was.
Der Typ hat nicht nur Nuke gefaked, sondern auch gecheatet. Der war jung.
Mach mal Optik Predator. Okay, das ist dann das letzte, lass mal gucken.
Optik Predator Montage, welche denn?
Das da, Predators, Optik Predator. Ach die da, ja genau, da kann ich mich auch noch dran erinnern. Die war auch ziemlich gut.
Aber auch Kack-Quali.
Wisst ihr was ich mache? Ich wollte heute eigentlich was auf... Wie gesagt, ich habe mir ja schon was überlegt.
Ich versuche mal ein MW2 zu installieren und ich schneide einfach mal irgendwie so 2 Stunden MW2 mit und schneide dann irgendwie...
Also ich lame mal ein bisschen Spiel MW2 und schneide dann mal ein Video draus zusammen.
SteviCod4, die müssen wir auch gucken. SteviCod4 müssen wir noch gucken. SteviCod4 war auch Legendary.
Das gucken wir noch. Okay, wir gucken noch die Optik Predator Montage und danach gucken wir noch SteviCod4.
Streamverbot anders geabonniert, Stufe 1, Dankeschön, Pog.
Mato, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, Pog. Heute geht's ja Schlag auf Schlag. Soll ich mal kurz bevor die Montage anfängt,
soll ich mal gucken wie viel Subs wir mittlerweile schon haben. Guck mal, ich guck mal wie viel Subs wir haben.
Also wir, wir ist jetzt doof gesagt, also ich in dem Fall. Wir haben ja keine Subs.
Bist du bestechlich? Klar, Sellout überhaupt kein Problem. Bist du bestechlich?
Ich gebe dir meinen Preis ab, wenn dann die Montage hier anschaust. Ja, bin ich, bin bestechlich.
Zeig mal wie lange geht die. 49 Sekunden, das ist ja easy.
Ich bin bestechlich. Ich mag Sellout am Start, hab kein Problem. Gucken wir danach.
Aber jetzt gucken wir erstmal die Optik Predator und ich muss sagen gucken wir wie viel Subs wir haben.
Sunny, ja danke. Wir gucken uns jetzt auch gleich an. Also wie viel Subs haben wir? Mal gucken.
Schauen wir mal. Wo stehts denn? 245 Subs. Wir brauchen noch 50 Abopunkte für ein weiteres Emote.
Für ein weiteres Emote, wo ich kaum welche drinne hab. 280 Viewer und 245 Subs. Das ist massive. Wahnsinn.
Hätte ich ja nie gedacht. 245, das ist Wahnsinn. Es ist natürlich nicht viel im Vergleich zu dem was es sonst so gibt auf Twitch, aber für mich ist das richtig viel.
Erox, Stufe 1. Achso von Twitchman auf Stufe 1. Dankeschön. Pog. Wo ist die Rolex? Ich würd sagen ich brauch erstmal eine Rolex Tätowierung.
Danach die Rolex. Wobei ich würd das anders machen. Ich kauf mir keine Rolex. Ich kauf mir, dass es mir zu oldschool Geld ausgeben.
Ich kauf mir ne Rolex Smartwatch die nach 3 Jahren nichts mehr wert ist.
Wer hat letztens im Steam erzählt, dass er mit dem Creator-Code im Monat so viel verdient hat wie sein Auto? Ja, wundert mich nicht.
Aber gut, das kann man auch nicht als Maßstab nehmen. Ich mein es ist mit Abstand der größte in Deutschland und einer der größten weltweit.
Wenn nicht der größte sogar weltweit auf Twitch.
Man muss sich mal überlegen. Monta hat teilweise mehr Zuschauer als Ninja und so was. Als Ninja gehabt. Mixer und so. Ja, vergesst.
Das ist auf jeden Fall krass. Das kann man jetzt nicht als Maßstab nehmen. Das ist das Top 1. Das ist in ganz vielen Verteilungen so, dass die Top 10 so viel haben wie alle anderen zusammen nach dem Motto.
Das kann man nicht als Maßstab nehmen.
Natürlich ist unglaublich viel Geld. Deswegen verstehe ich es auch ehrlich gesagt nicht. Ich hab das schon öfters gesagt und da schließe ich mich jetzt mal mit ein.
Wobei bei mir macht es keinen Unterschied, weil bei mir gucken nicht so viele 12-Jährige.
Deswegen verstehe ich nicht, dass so viele 12-, 13-Jährige ihr Taschengeld und ihr Geld Streamern geben.
Mir ist jetzt vollkommen egal, ob das Montana Black ist, ob ich das bin, ob das jetzt... Irgendwie ist es vollkommen egal. Ganz ehrlich, wir haben das alle nicht nötig.
Ja, die ober ich nicht und sagen wir mal hier irgendwie Montana Black, Ninja, wer auch immer.
Garantiert auch nicht, dass man dem sein letztes Hemd als Donation gibt. Man sollte lieber gucken, dass man mit seiner Kohle ordentlich was für sich selbst macht.
Und wenn man dann was über hat, ich freue mich über jeden Sub und wahrscheinlich die anderen auch. Aber erstmal gucken, dass man selbst ganz gut dabei ist.
Ja, ich weiß, dass viele mit 12 geguckt haben. So, wir müssen jetzt mal weitermachen, weil sonst kann ich kein Sellout mehr für...
Wie hieß er? MrEasy, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, weiß ich gar nicht, ob ich das gesehen habe.
Wir müssen noch Sellout für Sunny machen, klar. Aber jetzt erstmal Optik Predator Montage.
Ja, gebt euer Geld lieber Camgirls als Twitch Streamer. Mach das, mach das. Besser, besser aufgehoben.
Ja, kennt ihr ihn noch hier? You and Chris, baby. Gibt's ihn überhaupt noch? You and Chris.
Tief in die Preset-Kiste. Aber Editing noch nicht so das Ding, wie es heute ist.
Ja, aber die Montage kann ich mir noch erinnern. Da wurde die Intervention, wie es schneit. Hat sogar gemisst.
Okay, Quickscope.
Haha, wie zu editen. Diese komischen Reactions im Hintergrund, ey.
Ja, das hat mit Skill nichts zu tun, das war einfach scheiß Zufall, dass er getroffen hat.
Das ist wohl mehr oder weniger Zufall gewesen, dass es geklappt hat.
Ich meine, das war ein nice, nice ge-edited.
Habt ihr's gesehen? Moment, das muss ich mir noch mal angucken. Nee, das meine ich nicht.
Warten wir jetzt gleich. ETF. Haha, so geil.
Wie kann man das so sexy machen daneben, das sieht so hängen geblieben aus.
Ich hätte den auch gemisst, ich hätte den nicht getroffen.
Schreckt, Double schreckt, Desert Eagle schreckt.
Nein, Moment, das zählt nicht, das war kein Quickscope, man hat das Scope gesehen.
Also die Quickscope-Polizei, die damals am Start war, hätte das Exposed als nicht gültiger Quickscope.
Das Schild tut.
Ach, auch noch mit der Pistole, na das ist ja Chuck Dutty mit dem Quickscope.
Die ganzen Schneiber-Dudes damals, die ihre Sens irgendwie auf 20 stehen hatten oder so.
Einfach mal lucky getroffen.
Einfach mal random in die Richtung geschossen und getroffen.
Das ist halt übrigens Glück, ne.
Die Effekte, dieses Visier geht einem schon übelst auf den Sack nach der Zeit.
Die Effekte, das übertreiben das aber.
Der 360, der musste wieder sein, ey.
Und wann ist das, 2011 oder so? 2010?
Da fehlen ja jetzt eigentlich noch irgendwelche Wurfmesser-Kills.
Oder Wurfmesser-MW3.
Ich meine, man muss ehrlich sagen, das Editing und das alles drumherum ist cool, aber ich meine, die Kills, du siehst meistens einfach nur eins, zwei Kills am Stück und dann irgendwie dann nice zusammengeschnitten.
Und das ist jetzt einfach mal lucky durch die Wand gebankt.
Vor allem schnell sind es so da, als hatte er jetzt alles so calculated, was da passiert, ne. Das meiste ist einfach viel Spielzeit und lucky Kills. Ich meine, das ist jetzt nice, ja. Aber teilweise ist es einfach übelst lucky Kills, wenn du einfach dich 500 Stunden aufnimmst beim Spielen, da hast du halt auch mal gute Kills bei.
Okay, fertig. So, jetzt muss ich die Sellout-Montage angucken. Dafür habe ich seinen Twitch Prime-Sub. Die kriegt also Leute, ne. Ich bin käuflich, was das angeht, wenn mir Subs gibt, von dem gucke ich auch was.
Was ist das?
Das ist CS, das ist nicht CSGO, das Ding ist, das ist Source, oder? Ah, das ist, das ist Source.
Ah, ja.
Aha, gut. Was soll das angehen? Oh, kennt dieses olle, dieses olle Animationsding noch jemand? Das ist uralt. Das ist, das ist älter, das ist älter als das YouTube gab, glaube ich sogar.
Ähm, wir müssen uns noch Stevie, Stevie wollten wir so angucken, StevieCod4. Ne, so, ich drück mal. Stevie, 9 Lives, ich glaube, das ist es, oder? Ist das?
One Life Left? Welches war denn das richtige? Ich glaube, ich glaube, das obere. Ich glaube, das da. Oder 9 Lives? Ne, ich glaube, One Life Left Primer, das zweite.
Genau, ja, ja, aber das war auch nice.
Das war ein nicees Intro. Tengu Saka.
Da, da merkt man, da merkt man, dass das Editing, das ist noch ein paar Jahre früher, dass das Editing noch nicht so over, over the top war.
Und es war PC, by the way, kein Xbox oder so.
Das ist aber, glaube ich, nicht das, nicht das, voll irgendwas, ich meinte.
Oder doch, doch, doch, ist es, ist es. Ja, doch, das ist es. Jetzt wird lange stelzt. Nice Stelze. Bam.
Man könnte auch sagen, das letzte richtig gute Competitive-Cod. Muss den Fuß schießen jetzt, wenn er rauskommt.
Da, das ist das Edel. Aber der hat nebenbei noch eine AK auf, eine AK-472 aufgehoben.
Ebolon, das Sack.
Alter, jetzt wollt ihr es wissen. Moment, konnte man, konnte man sich lehnen bei Cod4 auf dem PC?
Konnte man sich da lehnen? Oh, das sah das nicht so aus. Das sah doch, man konnte sich bei Cod4 lehnen auf dem PC? Wirklich?
Okay, stimmt, man hat auch einen Replay-Modus, was ja damals alles als wahnsinnig Neuigkeit danach verkauft wurde.
Ich mach die Leiste weg, ich hab sonst immer die Leiste eingefädelt. Auf dem PC hab ich nie gespielt, vorsichtig.
MLC legit. Okay, das war Glück.
Colletero.
Das hab ich auch total oft geguckt, dieses Video damals zu contriert sein. Obwohl ich Konsolen-Plapp gewesen bin.
Ich hab's damals gar nicht realisiert, dass so auf der Konsole niemand spielen kann.
Diese Woche ist doch die neue Modern Warfare Beta, ja. Ich hab sogar Codes. Kann ich sogar ein paar Codes verlosen eigentlich?
Siebit, Super1, Dankeschön. Fuck.
Ja, ich spiel auf der Playstation 4. Ich hab mittlerweile genug Codes, das hat Glück.
Irgendwie seitdem ich wieder Videos mache, wählen sich die ganzen Marketing-Leute. Es hat sich auch einer von euch gefragt, ob ich ein paar Codes verlose.
Vielleicht krieg ich auch ein paar zum Verlosen.
Zellout. Ja, immer Zellout. Flipmode 23 für Prime, huge.
Das kann nicht alles funktionieren. Du kannst als Prime-Sub keine Emotes verwenden, das dauert kurz. Du musst refreshen und dann mal ein paar Sekunden warten.
Prime-Sub ist das gleiche wie ein richtiger Sub, da gibt's keinen Unterschied.
Obwohl, du bist überhaupt kein Sub bei mir, seh ich gerade. Du hast nicht das Sub-Eignen. Also, falls du mich wirklich gesubbt hast,
falls du mich gesubbt hast und es nicht geht, musst du nicht, glaub ich, mal in Twitch-Support werden.
Weil, das kann eigentlich nicht sein. Du hast auch keinen Sub-Eignen. Und aktuell sind die Subs auch billiger.
Ach, er ist nur Twitch-Prime und hat mich gesubbt. Ja, nee, dann funktioniert das nicht. Du musst schon in Channel sagen, dass du Channel-Emotes kriegst.
Ansonsten, wir haben auch jede Menge andere Better Twitch-TV und FMZ-Emotes. Also, das gibt's ja auch genug.
Dark-Fight, Twitch-Prime, nee, richtiger Sub. Twitch, ganz schön. David, aner-Squad, aner-Squad, aner-Squad, Twitch-Prime.
Danke schön. Flipmo 23, wobei, dich hatte ich schon, oder? Egal. Nice.
Kann man Code 4 eigentlich noch irgendwo legal auf PC spielen, oder? Kannste auf Steam kaufen.
Aber gespielt wird's wahrscheinlich wenig. Es geht jetzt ab. Ach, jetzt kommt die Messer-Geschichte.
Das, das war auch eine nice Montage. Ach ja. Das war schon nice.
Das war schon nice. Rapitler abonniert Stufe 1. Dankeschön.
283 Zuschauer, richtig viel. Schön, dass ihr alle dabei seid.
Beziehungsweise schön, dass ihr alle dabei wart, denn ich werde jetzt aufgehen, was futtern, was aufnehmen.
Vielleicht MW2. Muss ich mal gucken. Vielleicht nehme ich MW2 auf, wenn ich's finde.
Einfach ein paar Runden spielen und zusammenschneiden.
Wobei, eigentlich wollte ich was zu den Jugendwörtern dieses Jahr aufnehmen, weil, ich mein, guckt euch das mal an.
Jetzt kommen die Subs rein hier. Nice. Jetzt kannst du die Emotes verwenden. Danny D., Stufe 1.
Nice. Brauchst du Sniper-Gameplay? Wenn du coole Sniper-Gameplay hast, gib her.
Auf sein Nacken, genau. Jugendwort des Jahres 2019. Also, voting.
Ich kann nicht scrollen auf der Seite. Das Scrollen auf der Seite ist kaputt.
Ich kann nicht scrollen auf der Seite. Hier kann ich scrollen.
Irgendjemand hat den Scroll deaktiviert in JavaScript. Was ist das denn?
Also, was haben wir für Jugendwörter 2019? Das haben wir uns letztens schon mal irgendwo angeguckt.
Lachkick ist für den Arsch. Verwendet das überhaupt noch jemand?
Das ist nichts Neues, oder? Das ist doch schon uralt.
Cornern im Viertel abhängen. Also, in the Hood sozusagen.
Das verwendet auch keiner, oder? Oder ist das nicht neu?
Hustlen, hart arbeiten. Naja.
Habibi. Wie gesagt, dieses Jahr sind so viele arabische, türkische Wörter dabei.
30, 40 Prozent. The Doctor Magic, Stufe 1.
Noch mehr Abos. Dankeschön.
Bratan Bra. Heißt das nicht eher Bro? Come on, Bro.
Küsse deine Augen. Flexen. Flexen ist doch eher... Flexen ist für mich angeheben prallen.
Ich würde Flexen übersetzen mit... auf dicke Hose machen.
Keck. Möchte gern Weichling verlieren. Ich kenne nur Topkeck.
Das ist so ein Keks. So ein Donut ist das.
Topkeck. Oder kein Donut. So ein Muffin.
Hala Habibi, ich küsse deine Augen. Das ist ja grausam. Grausam.
Auf meinen Nacken. Das ist schon uralt.
Cringe. Das ist das einzige davon, was ich auch verwende.
Flexen ist entweder Pläsch schneiden oder schleifen mit der Flex.
Das ist wohl wahr. Ehre genommen. Ehre genommen ist, das verwende ich auch manchmal.
Ja Moin. Ausdruck der Verwunderung über was. Ja Moin.
Das klingt beknackt. Gönyamin.
Das klingt wirklich typisch Jugendsprache 2019 wie Gönyamin.
Wegen Kollegen. Dachte ich auch gerade. Dachte ich auch gerade.
Muss los. Ja das ist ja schon alt.
Aber wie gesagt Bruder muss los. Das beste Bild davon ist Bruder muss Kurs.
Getriggert. Das verwende ich auch oft.
Safe. Alman. Ein Mensch mit typisch deutscher Verhaltensweise.
Das heißt nicht, dass es ein Deutscher sein muss.
Das heißt nur, dass ein Mensch mit typisch deutscher Verhaltensweise.
Was ist denn zum Beispiel typisch deutscher Verhaltensweise?
Sparsam sein oder meckern.
Chuligom. Das finde ich immer noch geil. Das ist geil.
Was letzte Preis? Chuligom.
Chuligom muss gewinnen. Da stimmen wir jetzt ab.
Wobei eigentlich muss Getriggert gewinnen. Triggert ist viel besser.
Klar haben wir die Datenschutzerklärung gelesen. Easy.
Immer. Ich lese alle Datenschutzerklärungen.
Ergebnisse. Ok. Wie sieht es aktuell aus?
Chuligom führt. Alman ist auf 2. Safe auf 3. Getriggert auf 4.
Getriggert muss eindeutig weiter vorne hin.
Getriggert ist das beste. Heute sind bei allem und jedem getriggert.
Chuligom. Was letzte Preis?
Mein Cousin ist dumm. Der macht das.
Aber Cousin. Sowas von falsch geschrieben.
Das ist eigentlich nur deutscher auf türkisch.
Aber wenn uns das Jugendwort des Jahres erklärt.
Ich verstehe eh nicht warum da so viel arabisch und türkisch drin ist diesmal.
Wobei so viel ist es eigentlich gar nicht. Das da.
Habibi. War da nicht noch mehr drin die letzten 2 mal geguckt haben?
Das ist gar nicht so viel. Nur noch 2 Sachen.
Aber Brad sagt doch. Seit Jahren ist das doch Bro.
Was erwarten die sich eigentlich vom Jugendwort? Gar nichts.
Das ist diesmal so ein privates Voting oder so.
Was war das Langscheid Verlag? Die machen das dieses Jahr nicht.
Das ist irgendein anderer Dude der das macht.
So gibt es irgendjemanden den ich hausten kann?
Keiner da.
Also schön dass ihr alle dabei gewesen seid.
Ich muss jetzt Zeugs aufnehmen sonst wird das heute nichts mehr.
Wir sehen uns das nächste Mal. Nächsten Stream sind wir wieder am Start.
Ich weiß nicht mal. Morgen Abend oder so.
Also machts gut. Bis dann.